Sports bra, ah, this is out for donkey bread.
Wait, actually, no, can you just drink human milk?
No, I'm Indy, I can say it.
I have mine for it, guys.
Wait, do you want to, like, squirt each other's mouth?
Every angle possible.
Wait, that's so bad!
Finally, I have this.
I have the...
Oh, my God, can I say...
No, I'm Indy, I can say this.
I have mind break eyes.
I was like, wait, am I allowed to...
Yeah, I can.
Yeah, soulless eyes.
Sorry, I meant soulless.
That's what I meant.
Soulless, sorry.
P.G.
soulless eyes.
That's exactly what I intentionally meant, guys.
All right, I'll do three more requests, chat.
Three more requests, guys.
No, no.
You're not getting that.
You're not...
I'm not doing that for $2.
What the fuck?
Uh, we do it for a hundred.
Okay, yeah, I would actually.
Go!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, I'm so bad!
I like overlooking a lot more.
Yeah, that one's really pretty.
Okay.
I understand now.
I get why people want me in the dorm now.
Okay, guys, this is for science reasons.
I okay I was just curious if it was a different pose or
anything move the cap you don't understand Doki you gotta
move the okay how do I move the camera okay I now understand
wait she's wearing pants though right okay she's wearing
pants okay that's good okay I gotta go to the corner I don't
feel so good I need to go to the corner
I just have to be sure I'm sorry
My own personal show Let's go I got my own lap dance Caught
in 4k I am not even trying to hide it Turn your ass close to
me.
Tilt that.
Yeah, yeah, that's right.
Tilt it.
Tilt.
Yeah.
Yeah, there you go.
Tiny venom.
Come over here.
Now I need a venom in the middle.
Yes!
Get here.
Unlimited Venoms!
Oh my god, there's more There's more.
It doesn't stop.
Oh my god, it doesn't stop every angle possible Oh my god,
look at the hell.
She's just stuck between all the fucking venom, but she
ain't complaining This is my venom harem Oh no
She was in the way!
I was taking a shortcut I was taking a shortcut guys It was
an accident Why would you just stand there in the middle?
Like, what's wrong with it?
Yeah, I won.
All right, calling HKPD.
I broke into the street racing scene.
I broke more than one thing.
Let's just listen to Mozart.
All right.
Okay, so this one.
You freak.
Um, Jesus.
Whoa, Jesus.
Oh, somebody's going to hell and they ain't me.
Calm down, Jesus.
Jesus just needs a little assistance.
One second coming of Jesus.
Oh, my God.
hell if I say like isn't Jesus you know a virgin like sorry
well technically you were all here for this so we're all
going to hell unless we all repent you watch this stream so
you are part of the problem yeah oh there's a squirrel
squirrel water are you okay what's with this place where's
the water.
If only there another healthy squid around to help me.
But you want to like squirt each other's mouth.
If you think about it, when they're using water gun,
technically they're spitting in your mouth.
You use transport oh shit.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Where does the water come from?
If you think about it, I'm gonna I'm gonna squirt.
Should have been me not broken by the super chat.
Thank you.
Sorry, if I'm going to talk about it, I'll talk about it
with this.
All right, so.
The concert.
The concert was $48,000.
Jingle, jingle.
Jingle, jingle, jingle.
The funny thing is that I don't know what chat is reacting.
to it could be for the money or it could be for a jingle
jingle I told you sports bra oh that's right my sports bra
was working overtime that's a big number nice what if I get
demonetized I never had that happen before it's coming with
us really oh my god there's him there's Ruben can't wait to
and nothing bad is gonna happen to Ruben hey Ruben what are
you doing there little guy find any clues sniff out sniff
them out for me Ruben what no wonder you die guys I'm only
joking he's gonna live for a very long time guys Ruben I
need your help Ruben bring pickaxe to daddy that's right
that's right To me Ruben, yes, that's right.
I'll catch you
Okay, okay, okay, I'll catch him
Ruben I caught you remember Ruben Oh
Oh, he didn't like that.
Oh, did I do it?
Don't worry, everybody likes a belly rub!
Bro!
Okay, I'm stabbed.
Don't worry!
I am also a licensed veterinarian!
There's too many lizards out there.
We need to make sure we fix the lizard population.
Where the fuck is the...
Wait, did I stab everything?
Oh, it's because I didn't have my sword out!
Sir!
I did it.
I forgot.
I was like, where the fuck is your dick?
I just thought I was really good at my job.
I thought I was really good at like neutering.
Oh wait.
Okay, we gotta stab the heart now so you can stop falling in
love with all these lizards.
It's good for you.
Oh my god, it's back to the dick.
What?
Bro.
Alright.
Mmm.
Smoke.
Okay.
one more hit don't worry you don't need kids you can't
afford all the child services not child service sorry the
what is it child support child support this is what it's
always was like i'm just not wearing a sports bra right now
i'm freeing the goods y'all let them breathe sometime you
know you know i found out for the men out there for those
who don't know apparently actually i But you have to have a
balance between wearing your bras.
Because if you wear your bras too much, you're destroying
the elasticity of your bobs.
But then if you don't wear your bras enough, then gravity
does its work.
So you have to have a good balance between bra or no bra.
They need support.
Yes, but if you support it too much, it's like if you use
your training reels too much, you're going to rely on it the
entire time.
It works for the balls down there too.
For the men out there, you can't escape gravity as well.
You see, the difference is that we have bras.
This is out for donkey bread.
We actually know, don't think that.
Scratch that.
Sorry, I was thinking about her rhombus.
That's not what I mean.
Out of context.
Do not do that.
Wait, do I look presentable enough?
Quickly, she snags a mirror and we're hand-backed to
Inspector.
up before he enters the room oh my god what what the okay
okay um i think she might need to get it checked out i think
she might need to see what we're gonna call those doctors
for it
no oh no no no yeah she might need to say gotta call I mean,
isn't it exciting when it talks back?
I knew it.
I knew it was DDR.
What's that sound?
Do you guys hear that?
What the fuck?
Gotta lock in, guys.
Who adds numbers?
Oh my god.
I can't even look at the dance because I'm trying.
I'm trying to lock.
Oh my god.
i don't have f12 that's okay oh my god what the whoa this is
where you are i heard that you might depart tomorrow so i
came to say hello might you have time to talk oh whoa whoa i
always have time for you go on here it's time we've unlocked
a new route from the moment first met i felt your heart my
heart there is something about you that makes me think this
way guys do you guys feel the sentiment between me and
guanyin right now he's so mediocre i'm not gonna lie i'm
sorry he's such a mediocre leader well i guess you just
gotta convince me guanyin i'm sorry now i've set my peace
yet i find myself wanting to talk but which one's more rowdy
which one would You feel the same way?
Let us find somewhere to sit and relax.
Wow!
Okay.
Tonight, I wish to etch the features of your face up in the
sound of your voice into my mirror.
You just cut it like that?
What just happened?
He wanted to etch my face and my voice so he could remember
it before I left What what the fuck just happened I'm just
freaking around but like the official dialogue and the
official cutscenes Are so much worse than anything I can say
and like it just catches me off guard every time I was
joking and then it just got so much water no I think cats
are just somewhat lactose intolerant wait they're lactose
intolerant then why do they drink their mom's milk they're
lactose intolerant yeah I was gonna say if you're lactose
intolerant are you able to drink less milk or is that a
different type of milk are we just not able to digest cow's
milk because it's like a different species i don't know so
like as long as it's a human milk it's okay you're a baby
you're probably exploding anyway so it's kind of how would
you tell oh that's true you can just give your baby milk and
it doesn't matter because they're always shaking anyway oh
wait you're saying you can develop lactose intolerant as a
mutation like if you become lactose intolerant and you're
older and you really want milk can you just drink human milk
or is that frowned upon a society we're encroaching on a
different stop the conversation we can't we've already hit
our fetish quota i'm not a fetish yes it is a question if
you really miss milk and it's like you know is your favorite
type of drink.
And so like...
Then you have lactate or you drink.
What do you mean you have lactate?
You drink your own drink.
What?
Wait, Ducky, what do you think lactate is?
You said lactate.
I was like, what do you mean?
No, lactate.
Aid, aid.
I was like, damn it, that's freaky.
I was like, you're on your own with that one.
I'm not touching that.
I know.
I think if someone were to do that, They'd have much other
issues.
Yeah, I was just gonna say, it's like drinking urine.
We're like, no, no, no.
You're like the bad for you.